dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if a year what could
be a more delightful way to celebrate
New Year's Eve than reading about new
breakthroughs in machine learning
research let's talk about an excellent
new paper from the google deepmind guys
in machine learning we usually have a
set of problems for which we are looking
for solutions for instance here's an
image please tell me what is seen on it
here's a computer game please beat level
three one problem one solution in this
case we are not looking for one solution
we are looking for a computer program an
algorithm that can solve any number of
problems of the same kind this work is
based on a recurrent neural network
which we discussed in a previous episode
in short it means that it tries to learn
not one something at a sequence of
things and in this example it learns to
add two large numbers together as a big
number can be imagined as a sequence of
digits this can be done through a
sequence of operations it first reads
the two input numbers and then carries
out the addition keeps track of the
carrying digits and goes on to the next
digit on the right you can see the
individual comments executed in the
computer program it came up with
it can also learn how to rotate images
of different cars around to obtain a
frontal pose this is also a sequence of
rotation actions until the desired
output is reached
learning more rudimentary sorting
algorithms to put numbers in ascending
order is also possible one key
difference between recurrent neural
networks and this is that these neural
programmer interpreters are able to
generalize better what does this mean
this means that if the technique can
learn from someone how to sort a set of
twenty numbers it can generalize its
knowledge to much longer sequences so it
essentially tries to learn the algorithm
behind sorting from a few examples
previous techniques were unable to
achieve this and as we can see it can
deal with a variety of problems
I am absolutely spellbound by this kind
of learning because it really behaves
like a novice human user would looking
at what experts do and trying to learn
and understand the logic behind their
actions happy new year to all of you
fellow scholars may it be ample enjoy
and beautiful papers may our knowledge
grow according to Moore's law and of
course may the force be with you thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next year